[Applaudissements]
avoir autant était enfant pour une
rentrée non c'est vrai a lâché au 100%
de toute âme était beau tout cas merci
le boot a fait quoi cet été alors
plusieurs choses à ce qu'il était à skis
il a trouvé l'amour
alors non parce que déjà pour des dons
très simple j'ai vu un bouquin sur les
énergies pulsion de vie pulsion de mort
pulsions sexuelles et pulsion de
licenciement j'ai décidé de ne plus
faire l'amour
depuis déjà le beau but de l'été
jusqu'au mois de décembre je voulais
faire toute l'année mais bon déjà et je
vais essayer décembre et elle a répété
l'énergie sexuelle est transformée en
énergie créatrice
non je le sens des achats en forme dans
tout jeu crèche cartonne partout à st
ouais mais il m'arrive un truc
incroyable cet été histoire c'est sûr
que pas l'utiliser parce qu'il est très
fort
vous me connaissez la pub non nantis se
veut maintenant parce que je faisais la
phrase j'ai passé 48 heures avec une
star internationale
ce que je te dis est totalement vrai y'a
que jean michel qui est au courant vrai
ou faux quoi la personne tu te remets un
non non non non non non non non non il
m'a beaucoup fait mais je pense qu'on
aurait pu avancer un petit peu mais la
personne j'en suis fan mais pas au point
d'aller qu'edouard qu'ennemi
internationale vrai ou pas je sais qui
c'est wayne bridge et qu'ils aient pas
je suis sûr qu'ils aient je suis n'y a
pas eu d'appui gros ça c'est ouf
histoire des religions c'est vrai alors
américain oui non anglais we anglais one
tout ce qui s'écrit mr bean
[Rires]
vous l'avez également chez nous c'est de
le trouver hashtag star internationale
et qu'il a appelé le soir même et je me
suis non il s'explique c'est bon vous
êtes quoi habiller votre île de
l'émission avance merci donc allez je
vais quelques jours à nice avec un ami
d'accord
et puis mon ami en commun à justin et à
l'hôtel la baïne dit tiens on va est
indigné quelque part on a des muscles
s'est posté à mougins
bonjour bien sûr je riais travers on est
on reste dans le sud de la france
à côté de cannes à côté de 10 à côté je
vois qu'un ou deux gardes du corps avec
j'avais d'ailleurs c'est que j'étais
tout le temps à bouger en plus non ah si
j'ai joué beaucoup paddle là bas mais je
ne savais pas qu'il était là bas ouais
je t'aime où j'ai un vrai bon j'aime
beaucoup cette ville façon aulas
beaucoup des deux deux gardes du corps
qui étaient là-bas d'air notamment un
café des triceps un zaïrois qui étaient
ces on s'en fout c'est pas histoire
parce que si on commence à arrêter la
table d'à côté libournais plus loin
arrive à la table à côté la star avec
son ami donc déjà c'est une personne qui
est comme moi oui il s'installe à côté
donc c'est quelqu'un qui est en couple
celle sur une sorte de suite ou pas je
pensais plus est ainsi on essaie niel
tonnes ni john écoute bien assez à
l'écouté de mes stars internationales
dit me mohamed je te dis le nom arrive à
côté de moi avec son mec
elton john holmes qui est d'avis de sa
peine difficile en effet mais n'ont
passé
[Rires]
je dit pas un mot je te jure c'est vrai
ce que tu dis est vrai il raconte des
conneries store jeudi un bond à elton
john se regarde dans ces troubles et
pasquet new moon qui était trop où ça
m'agace et la courtoisie et j'avais de
bons mots trou oui et je regarde il à
ses grosses lunettes et tout ça
l'histoire est vraie du coup de coeur et
un moment le dîner passe et vient vers
moi ma vraie écoute bien s'il vous plaît
c'est vrai il vient vers moi et me dis
juste vous ressemblez à david beckham un
peu plus jeune alors j'ai alors là donc
été dit en anglais you see you lie le
club si tu ressembles à ton job ça
serait voitures sont beaucoup plus longs
et les mêmes new look david beckham
hanger indiqué me dit en anglais hindi
et me dit tu retires et c'est un très
bon ami à moi tu es mon petit beckham
français non me suis baladée penalty non
je déconne
on discute un petit peu en discute un
petit peu et je dis bajus très très
honoré la nage
écoute bien l'histoire et il me dit
demain si vous voulez demain après midi
j'ai obtenu une petite fête c'est vrai
ou pas gens me donnent une petite fête
quillan et de châteaux les maisons
magnifiques avec une piscine venez dans
l'après midi j'étais persuadé que
c'était une blague mais vraiment
persuadé et il me dit j'en vois une
voiture à l'hôtel je te promets que le
lendemain à 16h arrive à l'hôtel une
personne et je suis allé dans sa maison
jusqu'à 19h 20h approché elton john
shelton john y avait plusieurs amis à
lui qui avait pas ces enfants vont se
poser sur un bateau j'ai passé l'après
midi à la piscine avec eux en quête
adjani on arrive photo et coude non y'a
pas loin vers l'est l'histoire est vraie
parce quand je suis arrivé on te prends
ton portable
ouais on m'a pris le portable tous
avaient probablement été 2
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
dix français les sarments et je suis et
on a parlé de choses notamment de
coiffure un moment et il me dit voilà sa
moumoute qui est magnifique
il me dit j'en ai que deux comme ça je
donne un petit scoop génique et plus
blond n'ayez plus brune et pourquoi tu
color pas celle-là ça coûte tellement
cher
l'accord donc on a fait une coloration
bien devant cheryl cole sur la première
période nouvelle collection très drôle
et le lendemain je suis rentré à 20
heures ouais c'est pas digne et tout ça
et le lendemain avant qu'il parte lui le
lendemain après midi j'y suis retourné
il en retournait on a repassé la
prééminence et là on était sur le bateau
on était prêt à berre vers 19 heures non
non étaient beaucoup moins nombreux et
j'ai senti que si je voulais bah oui
ouais mais alors je vous pose et
dirigeants réels moyens d